hi everyone um i know that it's been a
really long time since you've heard from
me
um and when the news broke um
i put out a statement that said
everything i've done
has been legal and consensual and that's
true and i wanted that statement to
speak for itself
um and
i wanted to talk immediately i wanted to
post online i wanted to do my podcast
business as usual but
i i thought that that might not be the
best thing what might be the best thing
if i
it would be if i just take this time to
be with my family try and
uh take a long hard look at myself and
and just uh and do that and
um
it was it was a lot it was hard i
i first of all um i i do know how it
looks uh
with the uh with all the stuff that's
been
said and the the emails that have been
put out there and what the media has
been uh
trying to say and i know it looks bad
um and it it doesn't
show the full scope of the of what
happened um
i stand by the fact that all my
relationships have been consensual and
legal and
that's just it um
that's the truth
i threw this
kind of time away um
i've seeked out a lot of kind of um
you know medical advice therapy and
stuff like that uh
that doesn't matter here nor there but
what i have come to understand
is um this was always about
sex to me my life
was i mean sex
it it controlled my life
it it it was the focus it was my focus
um all the time
and i had a problem and i do have a
problem it's not like you
you you know months down the line you
just kind of
everything's better um i need to do work
on that
um when i first started doing stand-up
and i started getting a little bit of
notoriety
in my early 30s um
you know having sex got a lot easier is
the you know for the lack of better
words
um and i felt lucky i felt like
oh wow i don't need to work as hard
you know i can just do a show and then
have sex or roll into a city and
look at my uh inbox and then
just start writing and and i did man i
wrote
i mean i know you've seen some of the
messages online i mean there's there's
way more than that
i i would get 50 at least
50 messages after a show each city a
night and i would reply to all of them
and i thought in my uh in my mind that
being straight up with
these women was the right thing to do
i'd say hey come to my hotel room and
let's have sex let's make out let's
let's do this let's do that and
that was what i thought was right
i realized through all of this
that doing that
is just treating sex like it's casual
and
and being flippant with people um
and that's not the guy i want to be it's
not okay and i'm sorry for that
it makes me feel shameful and it makes
me feel bad
uh
you know people talk a lot about the
power dynamic and about
well why should someone who want who's a
fan of yours have to
worry about if you want to sleep with
them or not and
i don't i don't know where i fall on
that
you know i sometimes
think especially in my early 30s i would
be like well
the girl has the power because that's
you know they they i want to have sex
with them and and if they want to have
sex with me then great
but what i can say is the familia
the familiarity i would use the
film familiarity that
that i had with these women to
have sex i was like oh they already used
me they already know me i didn't have to
i didn't have to
do the extra work and i was talking to
one of my friends who
uh i was talking to one of my friends
about this
and about the power dynamic and about
the familiarity and not having to
use that and he and i said why is this
why is that behavior
uh not okay why is it not okay to sleep
with somebody if it's consensual and
they want to sleep with you and
and he said uh it's
okay well it is okay it's okay until
it's not
and that was when you know a lot of it
clicked for me
it was something
that just became
life controlling i mean
i would think about it all the time i
would i would go and i would do my show
and i you know like i just said earlier
and i just
it was too much and it became a
uh a lifestyle that i didn't know how to
stop
i didn't even think i had a problem i
thought that this was how it was i
thought that
guys in my position were lucky enough
and fortunate enough and
it just it was going out of control
and i i never stopped it i cheated on
most of the girls that i've been with i
cheated on my fiance
now um and this is my dream girl this is
the girl that i want to be with
for the rest of my life and even that
wouldn't stop
what i was doing and i was headed for a
i was headed for you know what i said
before i started for this um
and this needed to happen because
i wouldn't have stopped cheating i
wouldn't have stopped
using sex i wouldn't have stopped
so i have a chance here to uh
to really you know and i have been doing
the work and and being somebody who
is a role model for my son
and and i want to do that and i can't
i can't stress that enough you know i
can't go back and i can't
i can't fix that part of me that that
that hole in me that was trying to
be filled with that you know the
loneliness on the road or the or the
fear that i felt
or the insecurity that i you know i
would
i would try to chase and just conquer
with this
with sex and and it was uh
it was out of control so i have a chance
here to
apologize to the people
who got caught up in that [ __ ]
and
you know the lies that i would tell
my fiancee my friends my
and uh i'm sorry
you know i think that being a comedian
um
it's funny the the stuff that you tell
yourself to make everything okay you
know
like the cheating and the sex every
night or whatever
you know any guy would do this which is
not true or
um
or whatever it is and um i
i just
i don't know
it was too much and um i made too many
excuses
uh and i i can't do it anymore
and i haven't been and i've been trying
i've been on this path recovery now for
a bunch of months um
i'm doing well and
you know it's the hardest it's the
hardest thing ever to have to look at
yourself and realize that that's what
that's what
that's what that's what it is and that's
what you've done and that's who you are
and uh
so that's that but thanks for listening
and um
i appreciate you all thanks